So we're in a predicament. We want a small bin size to have as much detail as
possible about the location of data values, relative to the rest of the
distribution. But eventually, we start losing the shape of the distribution. But
if we have a large bin size, then we can't tell the proportion less than any
data value. We're going to handle this conundrum using a theoretical model for
our distributions. This model is a smooth curve that uses relative frequencies.
This is a theoretically continuous distribution that can be described with an
equation. This simple feature, an equation, allows us to calculate the
proportion between any two values on the x axis. We're not going to discuss or
analyze this equation in this class, but we can definitely go in depth into
forms if you'd like. Now what will be the area under this curve? This is a
really tricky problem. Just remember that when we had a histogram, what did all
the relative frequencies add to?